[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos del proyecto de ley en
francia que busca combatir el islamismo
radical y defender el laicismo es por
ello que recibimos a pilar martínez
basar ella es licenciada en historia
contemporánea y en filosofía francesa en
la universidad de zaragoza y doctora en
ciencias políticas por la universidad de
parís
muchas gracias por esta comunicación
empecemos por un poco de contexto por
qué es tan importante la y cisma en
francia uno de los primeros países que
consagró la separación de la iglesia y
el estado en 1905
es precisamente importante porque en
francia había vivido unas guerras de
religión importantes entre católicos y
protestantes y evidentemente esta ley
marcó el final de estas guerras de
religión y por eso es importante y hoy
es el día nacional de la laicidad pero
también es un día universal de la
elegida porque se celebra en otros
países además de francia
precisamente nos menciona que esta ley
se presenta justo en este aniversario
sería el 115 de ese día en que se
consagró esa separación lo considera una
coincidencia o es esto un claro mensaje
pienso que en el contexto actual es un
claro mensaje
es uno de los debates actuales yo creo
de primera línea en primera línea
francia cuando durante casi 20 años
prácticamente no se ha hablado de ello
porque la defensa de la laicidad era en
principio contra otras minorías
religiosas en la constitución francesa
de 1958 aparece evidentemente este
principio de separación de la iglesia en
el estado y dice la república laica
estará separada de todo tipo de puntos
hasta yo creo el año 1989 esta ley no
era ni polémica ni evidentemente estaba
en el debate de la opinión pública de la
línea de comunicación es a partir del 89
cuando el estado francés lo que entonces
se llama la reivindicación cero yo como
soy franco española siempre me cuesta
mucho hacer que la república sea
sinónimo del estado porque para mí es
una forma de estado pero bueno la
república francesa a partir del 89
considera este principio
la elegida fundamental en relación con
el desarrollo del islam político en
francia este es el contexto del que
usted negarlo seguramente y que es
importante reseñar equipo
señora martínez la seu esta discusión se
ha dado en medio de varios atentados de
extremistas islámicos en francia como
entender cómo leer este contexto que ya
nos menciona
pues yo creo que es importante la última
vez que intervino en su antena era
precisamente en caliente en el momento o
el terrible de los atentados de niza que
fue el 29 de octubre pero en el caso de
el contexto del que estamos hablando de
los atentados es evidente que hay que
señalar también en la decapitación del
profesor de historia samuel patxi que
tuvo lugar el 16 de octubre yo creo que
hay una relación muy estrecha entre
estos dos focos el primero es la escuela
francesa la escuela francesa pública
laica yo e igualitaria que se cree a
final del siglo 19 en esa escuela laica
insisto será acogida a todos los niños
cualquiera que sea su origen su raza o
su o la religión de sus padres en la
escuela es un lugar reservado de todo
tipo de enseñanzas religiosas y de
puntos el segundo foco en relación con
la cuestión de la enseñanza en la
escuela
evidentemente la cuestión de las
caricaturas y el derecho a blasfemar o
el reírse de una religión el estado
francés laico y que respeta a todas las
religiones pero no protege ninguna
declarado por vía de su presidente marcó
ese mismo día de la sesión a dos liza
que evidentemente en nombre de esta
laicidad hay en francia el derecho a
reírse o habla extrema de todo y que la
escuela debe ser es el lugar en que se
enseña ese espíritu crítico por eso yo
creo que hoy el debate es grande entre
aquellos que consideran que uno no se
puede reír de todo y que reírse o hacer
caricaturas del profeta mahomed o del
islam es evidentemente hacer correr
riesgos y otros dentro de una franja
progresista seguimiento qingshan que
evidentemente este derecho es sencillo y
alguna vez
muchas gracias pilar martínez-vasseur jr
licenciada en historia contemporánea y
en filosofía francesa por esta
comunicación y muchas gracias por su
compañía siga con más en france 24
[Música]